crank up the heat with j loose j lo's
tribute artist
connie p she's also known as connie pina
last night she threw a big celebration
for the release of her new project a
first for her
singing oh she looks just like her we
got the chance to talk to her during her
red carpet event for her new
song release
[Applause]
this is the first time you guys are here
my voice
with my music my music videos is
[Music]
that is a sneak peek at connie pena's
new single classical featuring cuban
rapper king lupo
also a vegas local
she not only looks fantastic but she
sounds
so good too she's been in studio a
couple times and every time she is down
here she's just a wonderful person but
it's always like j.lo is here
yeah i posted a picture with myself and
her and my mom
and my aunts were like oh my gosh she
met jennifer lopez i did too and i saw
her that afternoon
oh my god well connie also told us that
she's working on several projects
including one with tonight's show host
jimmy fallon
and also a new song produced by a vegas
local
with the objective of mixing the english
language with the latin flavor
i'm doing a little bit of english with a
little bit of spanish
and there the guys are gonna say hey we
want some booty
so it's going to be fun it's a tempo and
it pretty much represents what i
what i do you know what i have the
curves in the body
everybody
won't be released until next month but
in the meantime
you can check out clasico on youtube and
all music
platforms that's good yes good stuff
love it here's